So in the very first sentence or the New
York Times review of reservoir dogs,
critic Benson camping wrote,
it's been an unusually good year for the
discovery of first rate new American
film directors then goes on to list for
films that you've never seen by four
directors that you've never heard of,
none of whom lasted more than a decade,
making movies before continuing.
Now add to that list the name of Quentin
Tarantino,
I guess one out of five ain't bad.
Twenty five years after that,
Review Tarantino was probably the most
popular living working director in the
world after maybe Spielberg and Scorsese
is eight.
Films have grossed over one point
$5,000,000,000
worldwide and writing about his work
could fill a small library.
The quarter century milestone is a good
opportunity to look back at how
Terentino's first film has aged.
I have a slight obsession with first
with how things begin in the first shot
of reservoir dogs is probably the first
that I think about the most.
Okay.
Yeah.
Obviously,
I know this is not technically the first
shot of the movie,
but I've always sort of viewed the diner
scene that proceeds the opening credits.
That's a kind of overtures Terentino's
entire filmography.
Traditionally overtures are moot
centers,
a little bit of music that sets the tone
for what's about to follow.
It's only natural that in Terentino's
land,
the overture is a seven minute
conversation about Madonna songs and the
merits of tipping,
but society says,
don't have these guys over here,
but tip these guys over here.
That's bullshit.
So the first shot of the story proper is
this,
and it's one of the most electrifying
openings in film history,
like the first notes in the first led
Zepplin album.
Before you have a chance to blink,
you're involved,
your mind fans forward and backward
through time.
It's usual in film for actions to have
consequences,
but here,
consequences have actions,
actions to begin to imagine the heist
gone long
just like you're in the past.
You're also in the future calculating
how long this guy has left to live and
what can be done to save him,
and of course like Mr Orange bleeding
out.
You can't escape the present either
because that's what pain is a brutal and
specific attention to the present
moment.
It's that pain,
that panicked feeling of time running
out that separates this film from others
that begin in media read.
Whenever I create anything,
I always hold it up against the opening
of reservoir dogs is the beginning as
attention capturing as this.
Does it have the same kinetic energy
launching you into the narrative?
It's here too.
Of course,
that were introduced to the technique
that made Terentino's famous.
The nonlinear structure of his
storytelling and interviews Terentino's
compared the Byzantine tracks of his
early films to novel writing.
Novelists have always had just a
complete freedom.
Pretty much tell their story anyway.
They saw fit.
Alright,
and that's Kinda what I'm kind of what
I'm trying to do,
but while I think the comparison to
fiction apt,
I also think that there is a
relationship here again with USAC.
One of the things that I think help
reservoir dogs age so well is
Terentino's instinctive sense for
narrative momentum.
To me,
the ordering of the movie is a lot like
an under examined aspects of popular
music.
The sequencing of albums.
One of the reasons I love Abbey road for
example,
one of the reasons I've listened to it
so many times all the way through is
because the song sequence carries me
through even in the first half where
there's no medley.
The arrangement has thrust.
I mean,
just imagine the change in feeling.
If the album began with say,
maxwells silver hammer.
Now imagine the change and feeling
reservoir dogs began here.
Sales when motherfuckers Kev is doing a
job and take a big fat guess.
Once on a team.
The sequencing and reservoir dogs has
the same natural rhythm as an album
cycle does.
Offering a variety in tempo from intense
too reflective and back while linking
corresponding scenes together.
All Terentino's films are constructed
this way,
like albums,
more like albums.
I think that novels,
even the ones with more straightforward
narrative
black
coming up with an idea is to go through
that record room and go through those
records and to kind of find the music or
the personality of a given movie.
It's like I'm,
I'm looking for the rhythm that this
movie needs to play and I'm looking for
the spirit and the rhythm that this
movie needs to play it.
The other thing that Tarantino is most
known for is his dialogue and of course
some of the references in reservoir dogs
have an aged so well.
Well,
you know,
she looked like she looked like Christie
love TV.
Oh yeah.
Nobody today remembers the show get
Christie love,
but what's more important here is the
concept.
People still talk about TV shows.
Entertainment is still a common language
between strangers picking genre
characters and genres situation.
Alright.
And giving them a real life spin have
them sound like real people like me and
my friends and just other people and
make references that other people make
of war dogs translates into 2017 because
the humanity and the comedy that
Tarantino breathed into genre films is
still felt all over
footloose and in a great hero named
Kevin Bacon
teaches an entire city full of people
with sticks up their butts that dancing.
So greatest thing there is I think the
only context in which reservoir dogs has
an age so well is within Terentino's own
demography for all the purchase it has
on film,
culture and popular culture.
It's still very clearly his most amateur
movie.
It's impossible to say how would be
received today if it was released
because so much of cinema in the past 25
years is influenced by the style.
But I think siskel and Ebert got pretty
close in their original reviews.
I liked that movie as far as it went.
I wanted it to go further and try more.
I had the same reaction,
Roger,
that it was a lot of exercise in style,
but then I got that really quick.
I mean I understand what he's trying to
do here,
which is which is to show things in
crime,
movies that crime movies don't show,
for example,
the sloppiness,
the humor,
but we get that within 15 minutes.
The missing piece to reservoir dogs is
the deeper character studies and
exploration of big ideas that you get in
pulp fiction and Jackie Brown,
inglorious bastards and Django
unchained.
However,
I do think that there is one point in
reservoir dogs were Tarantino does reach
for something deeper.
The commode story sequence,
all of Tarantino's work comments on the
nature of storytelling itself,
but the part when Mr Orange and
undercover cop learns a fake story to
sell the criminals on his credibility is
one of the best instances of this in all
his movies.
He splits the sequence into four parts
are in learning the scene,
orange,
rehearsing the scene,
orange performing the story for an
audience.
Then finally the story coming alive.
It's an elegant illustration of how
words can transform into stories and
stories into reality or into movies and
it's a nice touch that the only thing
that keeps the cops from noticing the
drugs is the similar storytelling
situation because stories can keep us
from seeing reality too.
Buddy,
I'm going to shoot you in the face if
you don't put your hands on the dash
as an exercise in genre and style.
Reservoir dogs is super one of the best
in film and if it falls just short of
the transcendent heights,
that Tarantino would later go on to
reach,
but that's not really a criticism
because I mean,
let's see.
You try to reach just short of
transcendent with your first movie.
I think a good rule of thumb for how
well films have aged is simply whether
or not we keep watching them.
Twenty five years on.
I'm still watching reservoir dogs and
I'll bet that it'll still be true 25
years and more from that.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
verve.
Verve is a service that pulls together a
lot of great content channels like
rooster teeth,
Mondo tested,
cartoon,
hangover,
crunchy roll,
and funimation school.
To have those two in the same place.
You can download the verve app on Xbox,
playstation,
Ios,
or Android,
and if you get the verb combo pack at
this link,
you can get a seven day free trial and
once you get that Combo pack,
I'd recommend that you watch a show
called March comes like a lion on a
crunchy roll.
It's a show about a 70 year old shogi
player show.
He is a Japanese form variation on
chest.
Really good.
It's beautiful.
Melancholy.
I think you'll really love it.
Also,
Adam savages,
one day builds on tested is just a great
time.
All the shows are in hd and ad free.
I definitely recommend checking out the
verve APP.
I'll see you guys next time.